hey
how are you welcome to it's got to do
for laura new
youtube's favorite show that never gets
taken down and have any copyright issues
or anything it's a great idea of a shot
thank you
thank you let's begin the rule is simple
of course
scratch florida let's
go i get tim [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm down where's your friends huh
right there
good strong first clip very comedic
timing
i'm down where's your friends huh
where's your friends huh i don't have
any friends oh wait
thank you right there pubg
why are people still playing it god i
still play it too
okay guy white
scary eyes he was in a white button
shirt and black trousers
stay here it's safe i got this
bald guy white scary
he was in a white button shirt and black
trousers
stay here it's safe i got this
[Laughter]
stay here it's safe i got this
genius absolute madman stay here
it's safe stay here it's safe
the guys are like oh [ __ ] he's right
there i'm out
you stay here and die i ain't going down
all right hilarious
so funny what else do we have
[Music]
okay all right sure sure
funny and relatable location
why are they walking in front of him oh
that's so annoying oh man that reminds
me of this clip that's like going viral
right now let me see if i can find it
so funny oh found it are you rushing all
the way around
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
it doesn't hurt that much like this
squealing little baby come on get out of
here
[Applause]
what are you doing everyone's like what
friendly fire in fps lobby everyone
[Applause]
so good little kids getting hurt
it should be such joy
twisted it's got two colors
oh that's cool man that's really cool i
want to try that flavor
seems delicious money on your mouth
it's like illegal fireworks or some
something like that
oh jesus christ
[Music]
get the water
[Music]
get the water get the water you can't do
the full joke but
you get the idea get the water it's
funny like the water is going to do
anything that's hilarious you'd need at
least
a lot of water to extinguish the flame
all right what do we got
a good old without no sound oh
oh is he going to oh my god
that's some wrestle moves somebody's
added in some wrestling sh
on that god damn randy orton a place
we've never seen him before
he just got chad left out man god damn
skadooska day
i'm gonna let this one slide okay this
one gets a
pass you gotta pass you got a way pass
oh my god i've seen this one
it's so weird
please don't touch please don't talk to
him don't touch him
he's a service dog and you're
distracting when you're talking to him
sorry thank you
oh well i don't like
your attitude it is kind of annoying
like even with edgar
it's hard to get anywhere because
everyone wants to pet him because he's
just so damn cute
aren't you little anger yes that's right
i am so cured that everyone
just wants to pet me all the time and we
never get anywhere when we want to go
outside isn't that right folks
and then you say don't pet him he's a
service dog
don't touch it he's distracting how old
are you now edgar
seven you're seven years old and why
are you acting like a baby
next time i'm gonna get you if you try
and cuddle my dog
you're spreading germs okay you're
spreading your germs on my dog
right am i the only one thinking this
i'm not a germaphobe or anything
it's more like you don't want i'm gonna
i want to kiss angie
and i don't want to kiss with your hands
as bad that's what's wrong right now
everybody trying to rap the same style
uh i don't know who created it if it was
future amigos but all them
sound the same
[Music]
that was dope snoop come on man get with
the times man
get with you the rap youth man the gucci
gangs come on snoop
huh oh great look at that skedaddle
skidaddle skidoodle your
[Laughter]
oh oh should we just give up and not
monetize this one and it'd be
actually funny damn that got me good man
jesus christ i've seen this one it is
the most painful thing
you'll ever watch this is person that's
doing standards
oh wait i'm sorry this is something back
by that
convention what the heck was i thinking
hello
already already you know it's gonna it's
gonna be bad
i'm just so happy to be here so there's
anybody here a weird story uh anyone
frozen hands
hey you you in the back i saw that hand
go a lot okay without further ado like
let's just get this show on the road so
i can
enjoy my life anyways so
um i was taking a shower one day and i
was getting ready for school
it was good to hearing a story when
someone is uh literally
just doesn't seem like they're really
paying attention to what they're doing
and almost like it doesn't matter what
their message is because they're just
doing something else you never feel that
way
something i can't even remember what i
was getting ready for because i have the
worst memory in the planet apparently
um oh my god she has the worst memory
on the planet that is crazy
right here we are watching the worst
memory of the planet person
that's crazy that's crazy
i had to come in and use the bathroom
and um
um and from what i've heard from her and
she noticed my
my um underwear like crawl under the
doorway
which was weird it was like just inching
under the doorway bit and then she
turned around and went like
ah ophelia i think your underwear just
crawled under the door
and i just remember going like this is
painful
and i and i remember thinking what the
heck was she smoking because whatever it
was i gotta get her to quit
fast because you know it's kind of like
that one like that
you know whatever the heck you want to
call it and you just go like
like i'll lay off i thought we have to
triple shots of espresso
is that a joke in there or somewhere
there must have been
there must have been a joke it was a
stand-up stand-ups
have jokes
[Music]
[Applause]
is that the faucet making that noise
[Music]
what the hell is with russians man
this video would have been great if i
have to look at his man's nipple
dangling up and down the whole time
distracting -2 points
[Music]
oh my god this is one of those
volley bollywood movies
are they gonna yeah they are
okay
great fantastic why not
the shield protects the fall of course
oh yes
it's a weird i kind of want to see this
film why does indians
not to over generalize of course why do
people in the eastern region
filmmaking scene make such badass films
come on look at this why are indian
films just like anime recrea
live anime action look at that [ __ ] man
come on incredible
[Music]
i love that clip so much it brings me so
much joy all right this one is [ __ ]
brilliant
look at this dude come on man
that's not how you use a ladder did no
one tell you that no one tell this man
how you use a letter
oh that has to be on purpose it has to
be a joke
scared on the lighter just get on top of
the ladder please
please get on top of the ladder ah he
never gets oh he got it he got it
finally
wow that man sure knows how to use a
ladder
man down where you from i gotta find the
source to this
clip he burned my patch oh this is old
oh the person recording shoots the kid
because the kid had made a
video of himself burning his old team
patch but the guy recording
who was on the team of the whose patch
was burned happened to recognize him
the actions of the persons were uh
absolutely ridiculous and puts bad name
to airsoft a little criticism and a
burnt patch doesn't justify something
like this ah fair enough
he just forgot to disable friendly
fighting
if he's just a little kid right that he
shouldn't be playing the game
on that note we are going to end this
episode of
leave a like if you liked and leave a
like if you lost share this video with
all your friends and have laughs
together and don't or don't
check out new merch link in bio outro
shut up clock in and load up
[Applause]